RECOVERY.
WILL BEAT THE DISEASE AND AS I
HAVE SAID MANY TIMES, THIS TOO
SHALL PASS.
IN JOINING US NOW WITH MORE
FACTS WITHOUT FEAR, THE U.S.
SURGEON GENERAL DR. JEROME ADAMS
ADAMS.
WHY HAVE WE HAD SUCH --
THANK YOU SIR, I KNOW YOU’RE
WORKING DAY AND NIGHT AND KNOW
WHEN SLEEPING.
WHY HAS THERE BEEN SO MUCH
CONFUSION ON THE ISSUE OF
SURGICAL MASKS?
>> THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION AND
IT’S IMPORTANT FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT THE
TASK FORCE ALWAYS MAKES
RECOMMENDATIONS BASED ON THE
SCIENCE AND THE SCIENCE
ORIGINALLY TOLD US THAT PEOPLE
WHO WEAR MASKS ARE NOT
PROTECTING THEMSELVES FROM THE
VIRUS.
WE ACTUALLY RECOMMEND THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SYMPTOMS OR
PEOPLE WHO THINK THEY MAY HAVE
THE DISEASE TO WEAR A MASK SO
THEY DON’T SPREAD IT TO OTHERS
AND THE W.H.O., THE CDC OFFICE
ALL INITIALLY STATED THAT.
WHAT’S CHANGED?
WHAT CHANGES WE FOUND THAT THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE ASYMPTOMATIC SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS, AND SO THE CDC
CHANGES RECOMMENDATIONS TODAY
AND THEY NOW SUGGEST THAT THE
GENERAL PUBLIC CONSIDER WEARING
MASKS WHEN THEY’RE GOING OUT IN
PUBLIC SO AS NOT TO SPREAD
DISEASE TO OTHER PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY IN SITUATIONS WHERE
THEY MAY BE CLOSER THAN 6 FEET
FROM EACH OTHER.
ONE BACK A COUPLE OF REALLY
IMPORTANT POINTS THAT I WANT YOU
TO KNOW, NUMBER ONE THIS DOES
NOT REPLACE SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING TO DO
IS TO STILL STAY HOME.
YOU’RE GOING TO WEAR FACIAL
COVERING, MAKE SURE YOU DON’T
TOUCH HER FACE AND THAT YOU WASH
YOUR HANDS AND LEAVE THE N95 IN
THE SURGICAL MASKS TO THE
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
BECAUSE THEY NEED THEM TO TAKE
CARE OF HIGH RISK PATIENTS.
THAT’S WHAT THE CDC RECOMMENDS,
THAT WORKS JUST FINE TO PROTECT
OTHER PEOPLE FROM YOU BECAUSE WE
ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
YOU WEAR A MASK TO PROTECT ME
AND I WEAR TO PROTECT YOU.
>> Sean: CAN YOU TELL
AMERICANS TONIGHT THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH MASKS AND WILL HAVE
ENOUGH VENTILATORS?
THESE ARE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS,
WE KNOW WHAT GM IS DOING, WE
KNOW THE DEFENSE ACT WAS
UTILIZED BY THE PRESIDENT FOR
VENTILATORS AND NOW TODAY AS IT
RELATES TO 3M, BUT I THINK WHAT
EVERYBODY WANTS TO KNOW, 3,000
CASES WHERE I LIVE TONIGHT, NEW
CASES TODAY.
AND AMERICANS JUST WANT TO KNOW
THAT THE EQUIPMENT IS GOING TO
BE THERE FOR FRONT LINE WORKERS,
THOSE THAT PUT THEMSELVES ON THE
LINE AND PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW
THAT THOSE THAT GET REALLY SICK
WILL HAVE THE VENTILATORS THAT
THEY NEED AND HOW IMPORTANT
WOULD IT BE TO GET ENOUGH
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE TO NEW YORK
SO THAT ANDREW CUOMO’S EXECUTIVE
ORDER FORCING PEOPLE TO
HOSPITALS WHEN PEOPLE IN
CONSULTATION WITH THEIR DOCTORS
WANT TO TAKE IT WON’T HAVE TO GO
TO A HOSPITAL WHICH IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE BEST PLACE TO
BE.
>> YOU ASK A GREAT QUESTION
ABOUT SUPPLIES AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE STOCKPILE TO
MAKE SURE PLACES LIKE
NEW YORK CITY ARE GETTING WHAT
THEY NEED WHEN THEY NEED IT.
AND THAT’S NOT TO SAY THAT
YOU’RE GOING TO GET 30,000
VENTILATORS.
THAT’S TO SAY IF YOU NEED 200
VENTILATORS TOMORROW, WE WILL
MAKE SURE YOU GET 200
VENTILATORS TOMORROW SO EVERYONE
HAS A VENTILATOR.
THE PRESIDENT IS ALSO WORKING ON
THE SUPPLY CHAIN TO CREATE NEW
SUPPLY, WORKING ON REALLOCATING
SUPPLIES LOCALLY, BUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING FOR PEOPLE TO
KNOW IS THE WAY DID NOT RUN OUT
OF VENTILATORS IS TO MAKE SURE
SO MANY PEOPLE DON’T NEED
VENTILATORS AND THAT’S WHY WE
EXTENDED THE GUIDELINES FOR
ANOTHER 30 DAYS.
WE NEED TO DRIVE DOWN DEMAND AND
NOT SO MANY PEOPLE OUT THERE
SPREADING THE DISEASE TO EACH
OTHER SO WE DON’T RUN OUT OF
SUPPLIES.
>> Sean: I HAVE DR. OZ ON MY
RADIO TV SHOW WHO HAS TALKED A
LOT ABOUT HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
YOU’VE BEEN READING ABOUT IT.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> I THINK THERE’S PROMISING
DATA OUT THERE AND DR. OZ AND I
TALKED, DR. TORRES, WE TALK ALL
THE TIME ALONG WITH OTHER PEOPLE
ON THE TASK FORCE AND THERE IS
SOME PROMISING DATA OUT THERE.
>> Sean: IF YOU CONTRACTED
THIS, WOULD YOU TAKE IT?
>> IF I CONTRACTED IT, I
WOULDN’T NECESSARILY TAKE IT
RIGHT AWAY.
I WOULD TALK TO MY DOCTOR.
I HAVE RISK FACTORS AND MANY
PEOPLE KNOW THAT I’VE TALKED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT I AM
PREDIABETIC AND I HAVE A LUNG
DISEASE.
I WOULD TALK TO MY DOCTOR AND
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT WE FELT
MY COURSE WAS SUCH THAT I WAS
SOMEONE WHO SHOULD TAKE THAT BUT
I THINK EVERY PATIENT SHOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO
THEIR DOCTOR ABOUT THIS AND MAKE
A DECISION THAT’S RIGHT FOR THEM
SINCE IT’S STILL IN EXPERIMENTAL
DRUG AT THIS POINT.
>> Sean: THAT’S A GOOD POINT,
EVERYONE HAS THEIR OWN
UNDERLYING ISSUES AND CONSULTING
YOUR DOCTOR IS KEY ON THAT.